je suis un très grand fan de cet iphone
10r avec ce dos rouge prend du trail je
trouve vraiment magnifique et en plus ce
que j'adore vraiment là-dessus c'est
cette caméra
la forme de cette caméra comme elle est
positionnée je trouve qu apple a
vraiment fait un super boulot dessus
c'est vraiment un produit qui est tout
simplement magnifique
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a reçu un collier ça va
vous plaire regardez-moi ça aujourd'hui
c'est un déballage un peu particulier ça
commence bien aujourd'hui c'est un
déballage un peu particulier parce que
on va parler du deuxième un troisième
iphone de cette année c'est l'iphone 10r
modèle raid j'ai l'impression tous les
influenceurs ont choisi le modèle raid
je sais pas si vous suivez un peu les
sorties d'apple mais en règle générale
au mois de mars
apple nous sort d'un producteur ed qui
est déclinaison du produit sorti
quelques mois auparavant et qui cette
fois ci est un partenariat avec red
steel association de lutte contre le vih
aux états unis est là cette fois ci pour
l'iphone diffèrent qui est sont les
iphone coloré iphone un peu low cost
vers les grandes villes mais quand je
dis ça vous allez voir je vous explique
un petit peu ce qui là dedans
d'ici quelques secondes on a le
producteur ed je les trouvais y faire
cette vidéo que je pense que je suis pas
seul parce que j'ai vu que j vecteur
salut jb laver en raid fanny salut fanny
la regrette pas je pense que on est très
nombreux à l'avoir choisie au raid pour
croire qu'on aime tous cette jolie
couleur grève donc aujourd'hui au
programme déballage de cet iphone 10 r
on va regarder un petit peu comment il
est fait je vais vous dire quelles sont
les différences entre l'iphone 10r et
life 10 16 et 17 max donc aujourd'hui
c'est le déballage et dans quelques
jours je vous ferai mon retour complet
par rapport à cet iphone le test complet
de ce produit et je vous dirai s'il est
bien oui ou non
et puis au final on se posera la
question dans tous les iphone de cette
année le cac lâche t iphone 10 r iphone
10 s iphone 10 s max là c'est un peu
compliqué voilà l'iphone 10r de cette
année alors bois kit simple a asséné
jungle qui tombe design très bien réussi
d'ailleurs c'est que dans ce sens on
voit l'encoche ici forcément elle est en
rouge
la pomme est en rouge tout est en rouge
très bien réussi dans cette un design
très classique d'apple version 64 giga
on va pas tourner autour du pot déjà je
vous ai déjà dit dans la vidéo de test
de l'iphone 10s je trouve que tout est
toujours très bien étudié du côté de
chez apple ne serait-ce que l'ouverture
des papiers bravo toujours très bien
fait allez
on procède à l'ouverture ah voilà tu as
plus forcément
alors comme on est sur une version red
on va avoir ici le petit papier à
l'intérieur qui nous parle effectivement
des producteurs elle de la lutte contre
le vih en tout cas ce partenariat est
bien certain effectivement de dire qu'on
n'oublie pas la lutte contre le vih
c'est l'instant t manceau mais il faut
en parler protégez vous mettez les
capotes voilà ça je vous le dis mes
petites languettes à la tintin tintin
wouah alors ça excusez moi de vous le
dire un peu mais cette couleur elle est
magnifique c'est incroyable je suis un
très grand fan on te mettre nu 1 je suis
désolé bonjour bienvenue dans le monde
dans le monde des grands j'adore cette
couleur j'adore vraiment cette finition
raid et je la trouve très très très bien
fait c'est noté ici iphone 3 oct réd
magnifique extrêmement bien réussi il ya
déjà quelques points de différence par
rapport à ce qu'on peut retrouver sur
les crêtes 10,16 de cette année
notamment au niveau du châssis
ce ne sont pas des bordures en acier
inoxydable comme sur l'iphone dit c'est
ce sont des bordures en aluminium
vous avez toujours un dos en verre qui
vous permet la recharge sans fil d'un
induction l'écran c'est un écran lekouid
retina ce n'est pas un écran oled comme
on pas voir son époque dit c'est ça le
fun 10 s max de cette année c'est
relativement différents stands écran lcd
1 tout simplement
par contre la taille est intermédiaire
sur l'iphone dit c'est vous avez un
écran de 5 pouces 100 m en 10 s max vous
avez des crampes 6,5 pouces énorme
et là vous avez une taille de 6,1 pouces
sur ce produit
plutôt sympa c'est juste génial ils se
reconnaissent tout de suite c'est
extrêmement facile et sous ça que je
trouve vraiment vraiment vraiment génial
avec ses iphone cette configuration elle
est hyper hyper hyper intuitive ça
marche tout seul c'est vraiment
extraordinaire
pendant que la restauration est en train
de se faire sur les clubs ont regardé ce
qui reste dans la boîte
vous avez forcément votre petit bloc de
charges ici vos écouteurs en port light
ni ici plutôt d'adaptateurs par
lightning vers prise jack bon sens la
vue depuis déjà depuis cette année avec
l'iphone 10 et l'iphone ices max est ici
votre câble
de recharge usb pour lightning voilà
c'est tout pour l'intérieur de la boîte
au niveau l'écran vous avez une
résolution de 1792 pas 828 pixels à 326
ppp c'est même pas du foulage il faut
savoir que sur un iphone 10 s vous avez
une résolution de 2400 36 par 1125
pixels ici pas d'écran hdr pas de oled
vous avez néanmoins fait saillie qui
fonctionne extrêmement bien qui est très
rapide
une certification ip67 au lieu d'une
certification ip68 sur les fans du
cerveau fait la lumière en pleine tête
au lieu d'y voir une certification ip68
sur l'iphone 10 aces et l'iphone 10 s
max en gros vous allez pouvoir lee
berger sous un mètre et passe ou de m le
mutin c'est pas de le mettre dans l'eau
si vous le faites tomber ça peut vous
sauver la vie de votre côté vous le
faites tomber vous ramassez pour ce pack
qui est bien de risque avec une
certification ip67 en termes de
performance c'est exactement la même
chose vous avez la puce à 12 bionique
qui est là de nouvelles puces cette
année qui fonctionne extrêmement bien
qui est la même que celle qui est
présente sur les fundis ssl sur l'iphone
10s mac vous avez toujours des haut
parleurs stéréo enfin tout s'en va le
voir lors des phases de test à l'arrière
vous avez un optique grand-angle avec
une ouverture de f 1.8 donc très
lumineux et un capteur de 12 mégapixels
ici pas de zoom optique un zoom
numérique x 5 et un mode portrait
logiciel qui va se faire très bien grâce
à la puce à 12 bionique qui va vraiment
finir vous des tours et le mode portrait
ne fonctionne uniquement qu'avec des
personnes vous ne pouvez pas ceux
marqués aucune personne détecter vous
pourrez parfaire le mode portrait avec
un objet avec un animal ça ne marche
absolument pas l'algorithme est fait
uniquement pour reconnaître des visages
des gens donc voilà si vous n'avez pas
de visage ça ne marchera pas et vous
avez aussi une différence au niveau des
éclairages de cette vous avez trois
modes éclairage naturel
éclairage de studio et l'éclairage des
contours c'est tout pas plus pas moins
et vous pouvez filmer en 4k jusqu'à 60
images par seconde là où cet iphone 10r
est aussi très bon tout cas sur le
papier donc sans le vérifier lors des
phases de test c'est que apple annonce
une autonomie une heure et demie plus
performante que celle de l'iphone 8 plus
en réalité il va situer à mi-chemin
entre l'iphone 10 aces et l'iphone 10 s
max de cette année par contre en terme
d'autonomie vous allez battre l'iphone
10 et smack sur certains points ça c'est
intéressant en temps de conversation
nous annonce 25 heures c'est la même
chose que sur l'iphone 10 s max au
niveau de la navigation on nous a
11 15 heures contre 13 heures sur
l'iphone 10 s max en vidéo on nous
annonce 16 heures de visionnage de
vidéos contre 15 heures sur l'iphone 10
s max 65 eur d'audio la même chose sur
l'iphone 10 s max et vous rechargez à
moitié en seulement 30 minutes sur le
papier on a une autonomie en tout cas
l'air d'être vraiment top tous ahmad
vérifiez bien sûr quand on va le tester
d'ici quelques jours il a bien
évidemment eyeos 12 la double car si bon
une carte sim physique et une estime
néanmoins il a comme sur l'iphone 10 16
et 17 mars de cette année mais là où cet
iphone est vraiment hyper balèze et là
où se différencie vraiment de l'iphone
10 aces et de l'iphone 10 s max et sur
le prix il est 300 euros moins cher que
l'iphone 10 aces et 400 euros moins cher
que l'iphone 10 s max pour quelques
points de différenciation je trouve
vraiment très bien pour moi c'est un
super rapport qualité prix or tout ça on
va le regarder on va le tester bien
évidemment alors je connais déjà
l'iphone 17 6 max que j'étais sec a pas
très longtemps ma vidéo de test en ligne
peut toujours aller la voir
celui ci je trouve extrêmement bien
placée en termes de tarifs il fait 855
euros virgule 28 je le trouve
extrêmement bien placé ça reste quand
même un gros budget on est chez apple on
va pas se mentir on est chez apple en
2018 ont tous les cas ça reste cher
quand on a un smartphone de ce prix et
cette qualité forcément il faut le
protéger
il existe différentes coques alors je
sais ça fait toujours râler quand on a
un beau produit red une belle couleur à
l'arrière néanmoins si vous le faites
tomber un dos en verre comme ça vous
allez rapidement déchanté sur un produit
coûte quand même 1 855 euros vous
risquez tout de suite d'abord les boules
je vous propose donc de choisir des
coques up
ici j'ai les coques de mon partenaire
rhino chine alors il ya pas mal de coqs
différente si vous voulez le garder et
garder ce de là tout pouvait faire c'est
prendre un bumper par exemple vous avez
lé bumper pour l'iphone disquaires qui
sont juste là bien là mon mignon comme
ça ça vous fait un joli conte tour et
vous profitez de votre dos là alors il
ya plein d'autres couleurs ya pas que le
jeune si vous n'aimez pas les jeunes
et puis si vous voulez une coque
complète qui vous permette vraiment
devenir une protégée à 100%
vous avez par exemple 7 quotas qui subit
un joli avec un effet carbone bon là mes
tenues vous l'a positionné dedans et là
ça marche aussi très bien par contre
effectivement derrière
vous n'avez qu'un petit côté du
producteur elle voilà mais par contre
vous avez un smartphone qui complètement
protégé et ça en tout cas c'est vraiment
cool et pour vous permet d'acheter vos
protections à un tarif très intéressant
vous avez un code dit pour sandrine au
chili en bas dans la description vous
pouvez y aller comme ça vous avez tous
et au moins comme ça vous serez
tranquille vous êtes gâtés ces canaux
c'est pour moi je trouve cet iphone 10r
est vraiment bien réussi et en rouge
comme ça il est juste magnifique
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter par un iphone
viscères est ce que vous avez acheté
l'iphone dit c'est c'est ce que l'iphone
10 s max vous l'avez choisi cet iphone
dit cela vous fait de l'oeil
j'aime beaucoup les différentes couleurs
voulez sur le raid parce que c'est
vraiment très très très beau j'adore
cette couleur dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bons commentaires à cluses
invite à vous abonner à rester connectés
parce que les iphone on va en parler
très très très prochainement on va le
tester et aussi pas d'autres tests qui
arrivent le matin le mec 20 euros le
nouvel pixels 3 pixels 3xl il va y avoir
aussi le sony xperia x3 il va y avoir
dans quelques temps le galaxy s est du
côté de chez samsung qui va pas tarder
et donc à plus de patience et va bientôt
arriver ailleurs plaint des produits qui
arrivent plein de thaïs pas exclu et
puis on va parler très très très
rapidement d'ici quelques jours du web +
6 t donc vous invite à faire une seule
chose c'est à vous abonner à rester
connectés soyez ça je vous embrasse
d'ici là je le regarde je le thème
jusqu'où on peut tous les côtés puis
vous marquer ce que vous en pensez
à très bientôt vous embrasse ciao bisous
[Musique]